hello
everyone
well
we have entered into a new
chapter a certain
unmovable
from everything is
God
a certain
ineffability where you can't really
describe
yourself you
can't
conceptualize about
yourself
all you can do is be
yourself which is
everything which is
love which is
wholeness because
everything as it
is is exactly how you want it to
be so
the
show
simulation is obviously a reflection of
of my
beingness my
frequency and this new
chapter is really a place of the show
coming to the end of its
seeking and really into a new
era of
power and I'm really excited to announce
that the show is moving the recording
studio to Austin
Texas super
exciting I've been a
off traveling spiritual
pilgrimages last two years and so it's
been a long time
coming to finally
reroot the
show
and blast
off from the this
new
deeper always already here everything is
godness and so it's going to be exciting
to bring guests on and talk about
exactly this and to have their audiences
get excited about
this and
to inspire
more love and unity and
prosperity through recognizing that this
is just
one with
itself and bringing the guests and their
audiences into the incredible projects
that we're up to like homow DEC
centralizing basic needs
infrastructures chatting a little in the
live chat
there looking forward to
the
show thanks for the sweet
comments love you guys so
much the show will be live a
lot I'm really looking forward
to what we were up
to
where we had not only guests that we
were bringing on the show but I was
doing a lot of these direct
messages and it was live live unedited
unfiltered just directly to you raw as
it is with guests as well as with
sharing
with this
new
beautiful easy to set up and travel
with setup we have with these sure sm7
DB mics with these obsbot cameras that
are super small and lightweight that do
this very fun thing where they
follow
which is fun it'll be useful for when
guests move around and also when doing
sorts of
teaching they also have this
great Zoom functionality like this which
is awesome to
use you can actually see one of the
little OBS Bots
here they're super
small
and it all plugs into the MacBook it's
really simple and smooth and it runs
through OBS studio and that just means
that everything is much more portable
lightweight
intuitive
modular which is really important I have
a bunch of scenes that I've already
constructed here where you know I can do
things like
I can show you this where you know I can
pull something up online and a guest and
I can talk about
it
um we can pull up any type of content
online I can pull up videos I can pull
up my own
notes really seamlessly and
easily I have this fun split view also
where you'll see the guest on the other
side of
this which will be
fun making it easy to not only have an
angle on me and an angle on the guest
and an angle on the table but also a
split angle like that where you can
really see our faces up close as we're
talking to each other so you can really
see those micro
expressions in our
faces and you can see sometimes the
software on the obsbot
catches certain
unintentional zooms
there
yeah it's cool
seeing in the chat all the love and also
the
in interest in Consciousness as
[Music]
a subject of deep inquiry so much love
to all of
you so much love to
myself it's so important to really feel
nonseparation and
non-locality Omni locality you are all
local
you are
everywhere at
once this is
love it's so important to really feel
that and you'll notice that when you
speak about this you will find your
tribe it's really important to find
community that clicks with
this it's really
important and to create with
community that feels the same
way and you'll notice that when you
speak like
this that there will also be a
repelling it'll be obvious when you say
that
everything is this
one whole and this one love and
everything is
God that there will be a repelling that
will happen for those that are just not
ready and it will be obvious because it
will come up come off like
shielding it will come off like
defense it will come off
like hiding
like a desire to not be
transparent like a desire to still have
enemies like a desire to still Harbor
resentment against
others and to not look into that pain
and to not heal that pain and to not
surrender one's own
ego and it's it's important
transformational work to learn how
to be the bigger person and drop one's
mask and make the phone
calls make the in-person meetings make
the time and space
to
heal to
repent
I'm sorry
for whatever it
is
cry just
cry cry it
out and
hug and
connect and you'll feel the sense of
separation and hatred just dissolving
right then and there
it's so
beautiful it's been a huge part of my
process these last two
years and I wish this type of
catharsis for all of
myself I wish for you to free your heart
fully back into this perfect
unity and to create new Earth from
there
I'm so excited
to be sharing
content that is also
in
new methods and
mediums like
meditations really looking forward to
those also
mantras playing some
instruments
really getting a
nice just delivering really
good
messages
clean
transformative
short
Mantra
streams I'm so excited for
that I've got a bunch that I've just
been recording as they come
up and it's it's so
fun using these ancient
instruments in the
process so I'm so looking forward to
that
and yeah I love the ASMR to I'm such a
huge
fan I I'm a huge fan
yeah there's a certain Beauty in the
proximity
to the mic and these very gentle mouth
movements and capturing those and
communicating love in that
way huge
fan and together yes we will make
this love this laughter
this
Unity Prosperity we will make it
contagious yes we will we will oh comedy
is also another huge so excited about
the comedic side of
things
cuz adding the comedic side of things
into the communication of these simple
profound truths that everything is God
that everything is
you and you're
everywhere the comedic side of things
makes it so much more
fun
and God is in many ways deeply
comedic as we can
see
how can something that is
one
Veil itself into
war how crazy is
that and
how deeply is that really the core part
of the game game that is
played without the ability
to feel
separate we wouldn't have this
exploration so it's equally important
for the period that we felt deeply
contracted into being a separate
body as it was for the period of feeling
the expans into being everywhere at
once and this is the mag
magic of the
Indescribable the superposition the
Paradox the
mystery you can't talk about
it words will always fall short
in describing
yourself this is a very profound and
important part of
realization relaxing the obsession with
Concepts and
words relaxing the obsession with trying
to describe
yourself which for me has has been such
a a long
process but has been so
powerful it's been so
powerful well this has been a fun
update
so a big update
about everything is
God about really sitting in
that imperturbably
holding transformative space from
there creating new Earth from
there the recording studio rebirthed in
Austin
Texas with new guests
with new direct message content
meditations montras
comedy in this new lightweight portable
format looping the guests and audience
into home Dow into this new
decentralization of basic needs
infrastructures all of this is so
exciting and I'm so grateful to be able
to have this
opportunity and to be at one and in love
so deeply with you with all of
myself so bless us
all on our
journey may we all
prosper and stay tuned for
more